Tricia is in Huntsville
hi Tricia how are you I'm good Dave how
are you better than I deserve what's up
I'm calling about my mom I'm not really
sure how to handle her situation she has
taken FPU three times over the past few
years and she had to file for bankruptcy
and now she still doesn't know how to
manage her money yes she does come to me
she doesn't know she just won't do it
exactly and so now she's gonna have to
have surgery on her wrist and she's
coming to me because she's gonna have to
follow FMLA so she's gonna have to be
without some of her paycheck and she's
telling me that she can't manage that
she doesn't know what she's going to
date you mm-hmm what's the matter don't
really know how that what's the surgery
on the wrist she has some kind of knot
or something that's very painful and so
she's gonna have to have it removed
yeah how long has it been there probably
for about a year or so well I think this
is her wake-up call okay I think it's
time for her to stay at work long enough
to build up enough pay pay in a savings
account to be able to survive the time
that she's off while she's on FMLA there
to buy this drunk a drink they wouldn't
be able to drink right if you weren't
there to buy her drinks she wouldn't be
getting drunk right when you finance her
misbehavior you ensure it is going to
continue okay does that make sense died
or something I'm not trying to if this
is things cancerous and it's going to
cause her hand to be something but it
sounds like this woman lives from one
crisis to another than they're all
self-created definitely definitely and I
thought I was reading that in the mail
but I wasn't sure so I understand I'm
not trying to be lacking in compassion I
want to be compassionate
but continuing to assist her in this
behavior line that has been destructive
to her is not compassionate okay so just
completely let me tell you what I don't
know I mean you got to sit down and
figure out how you're going to do this
in layers but maybe you assist maybe you
assist her partially in return for her
engaging in behaviors that she knows
she's supposed to be doing okay but so
far she has refused all help that has to
do with her straightening up Wow I was a
little kid my dad used to say straighten
up and fly right you ever heard that I
don't even know what that means I don't
even know what that means I just knew we
better straighten up I never didn't fly
so I don't know what he meant but I
didn't fly right you know but you know
I'm talking about straightening up
behaved you know and you and I did I
mean cuz I he wouldn't whupped us if we
didn't do what he said so you know but
this so in this case we can't do that
kind of stuff but but I gotta just think
that's what needs to happen here for her
own good you're aggravated with her I am
because you'd love her because you love
her and you don't want to see her in
pain and she refuses to do the things to
cause the pain to go away mm-hmm that's
right and you're more concerned about
her behavior than she is so I think I
just said don't tell her all that say
you know I love you cuz let me tell you
when you do all this she's gonna get
pissed off and she she feels entitled to
your money yeah that's weird the
internet cloud calls out a boundary
violation in the book boundaries now is
she entitled to your money because she
misbehaves you're supposed to take care
of your mama
cigarette hanging out your living the
iron lung in the closet I mean come on
seriously
I carried you mama oh my gosh this is
the Dave Ramsey show
[Music]